good morning John I have some very
exciting news for me really it's just
exciting this for me I'm filling this on
my phone this is my old phone it's
showing the wear and tear that comes
with being a pretty freakin old phone
the the eight button doesn't work there
are pieces missing it is a great phone I
jumped into a pool with it I left it on
the roof of my car all sorts of crazy
stuff happened of this phone it's been a
great phone but it is now entered
paperweight mode and I will be recycling
it shortly and I have a Motorola Droid
now which does 3G and a touchscreen and
pixel camera and every other freaking
thing you might ever want ever and I'm
genuinely like stupidly excited about it
I mean I went from my phone that's three
years old to a phone that literally came
out yesterday so it's been like
Christmas morning here at the green
household buzz no one ever talked about
maybe I'm gonna do a review of the phone
later on but really what I need to talk
about right now is that I'm going on
tour next week I talked about which is
really lame so I have to talk about that
but first I want to answer a few
questions about this machine pones nudes
and what's going on with it
the first question does my order get a
guitar pick I don't care if you order
the bundle or just a CD by itself we
really want to encourage you to preorder
the CD because that helps Allen at dftba
headquarters get everything packaged and
shipped out at the right time whereas if
he gets all the orders in one day and I
just want it's harder for him to get
everything organized and sent out on
time so pre-order not just because he
get a free sign pick but also to make
Allen's life a little bit easier which
is something we should all be trying to
do number to view ship to my country yes
we ship to your country we ship to
everywhere there are people are the
shirts gonna be available outside of the
bundle well to be honest the shirts are
starting to not be available even inside
the bundle so that's not a question I'm
even gonna try to answer we have sold
out of small and medium bundles there
are some large extra large and extra
extra large is still left so if you are
large extra large or extra extra large
you're in luck everyone else will have
to wait and see if we reprint the shirts
which we may do but we haven't decided
yet will the album be on iTunes yes the
album will be out on iTunes along with
the physical release on November 16th
Hank I'm going to see you on this tour
that you're doing should I buy a CD the
answer to that question is probably no
and I probably should have mentioned
that in the last video so if you are in
San Francisco Los Angeles San Diego
Phoenix Arizona Portland OR Seattle OH
probably get to you with a CD before the
CD will ship to you and you can buy it
there and then have me sign it or just
hit me with it
I don't I don't know what you want to do
with it there but if you are going to go
to one of the nerdfighter Vince you will
probably get it quicker if you just buy
it for me and I'm sorry I didn't mention
that in the last video which brings me
to my last point yes I am going on tour
and I will tell you my friends
nerdfighter gatherings have been some of
the best days of my life so I hope that
everyone nearby these places will be
coming on sharing that experience with
me because it is so much fun so I'm
gonna put up a graphic right now it's
gonna tell you all the places that I'm
going to and then as time goes on I'm
going to make videos for each one of the
locations telling you more information
about what the shows are where the shows
are and what's going to be happening at
the shows and all you will have to do is
click on the place where you are and I
will tell you more information about
that event and that's all its gonna
leave this graphic up and play a little
song John I will see
Oh
I'm sorry Canada Vancouver was so close
but it just did not happen
maybe next time maybe next John I'll see
you tomorrow